[Musik]
im moment verbringe mein leben damit er
welche instagram stories mit frisuren
herzustellen an puppen köpfen nur
überhaupt auch eine sichtbarkeit zu
zeigen dass menschen sehen ich liebe
meinen beruf auch wenn ich jetzt nicht
arbeiten kann ich mache irgendetwas
anstatt eine sprache lernen oder ein
kochkursus online zu belegen oder sowas
seit 20 jahren hat im kreuzfeld seinen
friseursalon in berlin jetzt ist er zum
zweiten mal im lock down
dabei hatte der
bundesgesundheitsminister im september
einer aufgebrachten menge ein
versprechen abgegeben
ja ich hab's nicht ernst genommen ich
konnte es mir nicht vorstellen dass
jemand sagt ich kann jetzt versichern
dass auch zukünftig das nicht
stattfinden sie hat einen friseursalon
zu schließen man sollte dann vielleicht
alles dafür tun dass es dann auch
eingehalten werden versprechen nicht
gehalten ist dass die methode sparen
immerhin hatte der gesundheitsminister
dafür rhetorisch vorgebaut nachdem die
infektionszahlen im frühjahr zum ersten
mal drohten außer kontrolle zu geraten
wir werden in der politischen debatte
und auch in der medialen debatte nach
dieser corona lage alle miteinander viel
verzeichnen müssen
das gehört zur rhetorik sparen dass er
zunächst dokumentiert ich bin demütig
bei dem was ich tue aber dem oder
alleine reicht nicht man braucht auch
ein gewisses ein gewisses maß an
professionalität nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz das ja seit märz
letzten jahres novelliert worden ist die
verantwortung für die zentrale
beschaffung beispielsweise von masken
oder von impfstoff bei jens spahn legten
ja diese verantwortung nicht abgeben
so beginnen sparens pandemie probleme
frühjahr 2020 mangelware masken
not macht erfinderisch auch und gerade
in krankenhäusern der weltmarkt ist leer
gekauft die vorräte wurden nicht
angelegt weiter geht's im sommer als die
infektionszahlen niedrig sind und der
minister eine wahl app an den start
bringt die bahn ab das ist mit abstand
die erfolgreichste kroner waren es in
europa die app ist sicher sie ist
freiwillig und sie ist einfach
handhabbar mehr geht kommen sie ist eine
der erfolgreichsten apps weltweit bei
denen die kontakte nach verfolgen sollen
entpuppt sich schon im spätsommer die
app als flop die app ist im grunde mehr
lästig sie hilft uns in der pandemie
bekämpfung leider überhaupt nicht wir
haben 68 millionen euro ausgegeben für
die programmierung einer app die das
nicht leistet was wir von ihr erwartet
haben herbst 2020 die zweite welle naht
jens spahn plädiert für den schutz der
verwundbarsten schnelltests sollen hier
abhilfe schaffen um bewohner und
bewohnerinnen von pflegeheimen und in
krankenhäusern zu schützen und nicht nur
die die pflegekräfte selbst brauchen
unsere unterstützung haben mit der test
verordnung seit mitte oktober
schnelltests möglich gemacht deshalb ist
unser aller ziel dass pflegekräfte
gesundbleiben krankenpfleger sebastian
lutz berichtet uns im herbst dass er
sich vom minister irgendwie vergessen
fühlt jetzt sprechen wir ihn per skype
sebastian lutz ist heute dankbar dass er
seit wenigen wochen immerhin überhaupt
getestet wird
es ist halt wie so häufig bei dem gefühl
verbunden dass deutschland da leider
sehr sehr hinterherhinkt und dass auch
die sachen die der herr sparen immer
verspricht dann mit sehr großer
verzögerung dann wirklich auch erst ein
treffen von daher ist es eigentlich eine
frechheit dass man jetzt wirklich sagen
kann nach über zehn monaten wurden
vernünftig getestet
im november ist die zweite welle da und
der befund über die erfolge des
ministers ernüchternd selbst in den
eigenen reihen denn die infektionszahlen
explodieren
wir haben noch keine flächendeckende
überzeugende strategie für pflegeheime
das ist einfach so wir haben keine
flächendeckende überzeugende strategie
für schnell teste das ist auch einfach
so
doch das scheint rettung naht zumindest
laut minister sparen 27 zwölfter im
staat in deutschland angekündigt als
licht am ende eines tunnels die zahlen
sinken damals noch immer nicht es gibt
sie die hohe weihnachtsbotschaft in
diesem moment sind lkws in ganz europa
in ganz deutschland in alle bundesländer
unterwegs um den ersten impfstoff
auszuliefern
zuvor hatte der minister impfzentren
inspiziert die die länder in rekordzeit
aus deutschem boden oder auch hasen
gestampft hatten doch beispiel
düsseldorf hier wird das impfen sechs
wochen verspätet beginnen überall im
land herrscht leere
jürgen stein aus sachsen treffen wir
schon im januar
er ist einer von unzähligen
priorisierten über 80 jährigen die auf
einen impftermin hoffen seine frau
versucht ihr glück täglich bei der
hotline der mann ist schwer lungenkrank
jeder tag ohne impfung ist für ihn ein
lebensbedrohliches risiko jetzt sechs
wochen nach dem start treffen wir die
steins wieder nach wochenlangen anrufe
und online versuchen hat herr stein eine
nummer erhalten
ich habe eine vorgangs kennnummer so
heißt die nummer ich bin doch weiß dass
ich sie am 04
ich nehme einen das ist setzen ich weiß
aber nicht der 78 1127 einen impftermin
hatte immer noch nicht
daher sparen bemüht sich und ich war mal
lehrerin wenn ich eine beurteilung
schreiben musste über einen schüler oder
schülerin dann hab ich geschrieben sie
gemütlich da wussten die genau sie
politisch aber sie kann es nicht dass
das licht am ende des tunnels nicht mehr
scheint gibt jens spahn heute zu doch
bei der frage nach seiner verantwortung
lenkt er von sich ab der start der
impfkampagne war schwierig und im
nachhinein hätten wir noch mehr und
klarer erwartungsmanagement machen
müssen dann auch zu jedem landkreis und
zu ihrem land und zu jedem eu
mitgliedsstaat eine stärkung abgeben und
jeder kann das im zweifel zu den virus
der bund aber hilft uns das mehr
impfstoff hätte geholfen noch immer
fordert die pandemie in deutschland
täglich hunderte menschenleben
die verantwortung für die beschaffung
liegt beim gesundheitsminister am
minister sie haben zu beginn der
pandemie gesagt wir werden uns verzeihen
müssen aus heutiger sicht die
angehörigen derer die jetzt noch sterben
weil kein impfstoff da ist glauben sie
dass die verzeihen können
zuerst immer wissen sie
wenn sie so fragen oder debattieren dann
ist das das ende jeder debatte und dass
wir in dieser schwierigen situation sind
er hat eben mit uns allen im zweifel ja
auch zu tun
er wird sich seiner verantwortung
trotzdem stellen müssen auch wenn er
immer wieder den versuch unternimmt
vieles von sich selbst wegzuschieben und
uns alle mit ins boot zu nehmen wie alle
haben eine verantwortung gegen das
corona virus zu kämpfen und wenn wir
alle eine verantwortung haben hat er im
zweifel keine im kreuzfeld hatte in eine
hygiene konzept investiert doch es hat
ihm nichts genutzt für ihn geht es jetzt
ums wirtschaftliche überleben maximal
zwei monate hält er noch durch
es könnte ihn optimistisch stimmen dass
die politik in diesen tagen um
lockerungen ringt doch er ahnt schon
dass ohne im verfolger dass ohne eine
funktionierende strategie der nächste
lockdown eine frage der zeit ist